and when we met in cave Minister
raznikov was clear
Ukraine's Armed Forces need more
equipment and they need it quickly
president zielinski reiterated this
urgency
at last Friday's defense contact group
meeting that I attended in Germany with
approximately 50. of my defense minister
counterparts from around the world
president zielinski asked specifically
for tanks
and that is what I am here to discuss
the
sudo contributions
Mobility
foreign
today I am announcing that Canada will
supply Ukraine with four leopard two
main battle tanks in the coming weeks
this donation combined with the
contributions of allies and partners
will significantly help the Armed Forces
of Ukraine as they fight heroically to
defend their nation's freedom and
sovereignty
these heavily armored and highly
protected Vehicles provide Soldiers with
a tactical advantage on the battlefield
thanks to their excellent Mobility their
Firepower and their survivability these
tanks will allow Ukraine to liberate
even more of its territory and defend
its people from Russia's brutal invasion
these four tanks are combat ready and
will be deployed over the coming weeks
we will also deploy a number of Canadian
Armed Forces members
to train Ukrainian Soldiers with the
skills they need to operate this
equipment pending coordination with
allies
as you know
today's announcement means that Canada
is among several like-minded allies and
partners donating Western Battle Tanks
to Ukraine and given the complexity of
operating these tanks it is more
important than ever that we coordinate
our efforts tightly tanks are not easy
to maintain but their sustainment will
be essential to Ukraine's overall
success and Victory
to that end we are working closely with
our International allies and partners to
pool ammunition and spare parts today
immediately following this press
conference I will speak with my
counterparts from Germany from Finland
from Portugal and Spain as well as the
Netherlands to discuss how we can
collaborate to ensure the long-term
success of our donations
although I am announcing the donation of
four tanks today this number May grow as
we coordinate donation and sustainment
plans with our allies donations
I will emphasize as well that the number
of leopards that we are donating has
been carefully considered in order to
ensure that our own Army has the tanks
needed
to maintain our own readiness
to train
and to meet Canada's NATO commitments
under operation reassurance
as we make this donation I will also
express my sincere and heartfelt
appreciation to the many members of
Canada's armored Corps and Remy Corps
who have dedicated their careers to
operating and maintaining these tanks
your tremendous efforts have been and
will continue to be vital for the
Readiness of this combat capability
military
we have committed over one billion
dollars in comprehensive military aid
from a nasam's air defense system to 200
armored personnel carriers that I
pledged in Kiev Ukraine last week the
bottom line is that our support
continues now and until Ukraine wins in
short Ukraine's sovereignty matters
rules matter and freedom matters
Ukraine's fight to defend itself is also
a fight to uphold the international
rules-based order that has kept us all
safe since the end of the second world
war and that is why Canada's support
will continue
question is
foreign
my question
functions
decision process is
the the
what does it say about Canada's
Readiness if we can only send four of 82
when other allies you know look at
Poland are sending 14 of the leopard two
tanks and they're roughly the same size
as us well I think it's important to
remember that the announcement I am
making today about four tanks comes with
spare parts ammunition and training
furthermore there is a possibility that
this number could grow based on the
conversations that I am having with our
allies and our ability to ensure that we
have the spare parts and the sustainment
necessary to continue to allow further
support further donations
Etc but I will say and in close
collaboration with with the CDs here
beside me that we need to make sure that
our army has the right number of Tanks
to train and to meet our NATO
commitments also so there is the
possibility of further donations I am
here to say today that we will undertake
four donations in the coming weeks I am
leaving this press conference to go
speak with our allies about how we can
ensure the delivery of spare parts and
the interoperability and the common
platform that is necessary to ensure the
capabilities are sustained it if I could
just if I could just say one more thing
um so I've been participating in the
Ramstein group of countries for almost a
year now
and
at the very first meeting I made the
point that we need to have a common
platform
across our allies so that we provide
effective
capabilities to Ukraine that are usable
on the battlefield and that means not
only the capability in terms of the tank
itself but it also means training and it
also means maintenance and support
so when I announced the 200 vehicles for
example that didn't just come that
donation didn't just come with the
donation of the vehicles it also comes
with training and maintenance support so
this is the type of approach we are
taking collectively with our allies
ensuring that we have a platform of
vehicles that will be important for
their Readiness in terms of their
victories which we've already seen in
the North in the East and in the south
is
foreign
[Music]
conversation
is a
SASE dance
without degrading the Army's operational
capability and how quickly will your
government replace those things we will
replace the tanks as soon as possible
and as you may know we are undertaking
the defense policy update to ensure at
all times that the Canadian Armed Forces
have the capabilities that they need to
defend this country and to remain in a
state of Readiness we are so fortunate
today to have the chief of Defense staff
with us who is the former commander of
the army as well as the commander of
third division and in western Canada and
I'll ask him if he would like to speak
to this issue as well
so I would just like to speak to the
number of tanks and some of the the
factors that went into that you know
firstly um we have to take a look at the
size of our Fleet
um and compared to many of our European
allies our Fleet is relatively small
there are several thousand of these
tanks in uh in Europe we also have to
take a look at serviceability rates and
the tanks that we are sending are
serviceable they are ready
um we also have to take a look at the
sense of urgency that is required to get
these over remember we live in North
America and to get a 62-ton uh tank over
there it's going to take takes I'm doing
so over the last number of weeks we've
been we've been planning working behind
the scenes to rapidly get this
capability uh over there uh probably
gonna do it by our with our c-17s
remember we can only carry one tank per
flight so the effort to get those over
is going to be something serious you
know in terms of future donations I will
give advice to government on that and
it's based on a number of things uh one
what can we do with our allies in terms
of serviceability spare parts technical
support ammunition we have to look at
this as a as a collective I've been
having some deep conversations with with
allies over the last week including
face-to-face in Europe last week I've
talked to my German counterpart three
times I've lost six days including a
call yesterday to discuss this very
issue so this is uh this is where we are
I'd also like to say very very happy
with our armored Core our maintainers
and those who have poured sweat and love
into these tanks and they're going to
continue
what Russia the Optics attacks today in
Wisconsin this saying it is an
escalation can you respond to that what
do you what is your response to them
well Russia will use any excuse to uh to
launch further attacks and and they will
grab onto uh any shred of uh credibility
that they can find uh but uh I don't put
much Credence in in that uh if they want
to de-escalate they can leave Ukraine
attack ones we use for training are
these ones that be sent on operations
otherwise so these are leopard two a4s
the same as a number of our allies are
providing including Poland and that will
allow us to have interoperability of
training of spare parts and ammunition
are these the older tanks these ones we
were using for training or these ones
that we would have sent out they are
operational tanks uh we've used them for
training uh but also many countries in
the world have used them for operations
as well
so I don't have those technical details
and um if I did I wouldn't be able to
share them because that's something we
don't want out there in terms of
generally speaking how like are these
are these so compared to what the
Russians are using t-72s Etc yeah much
much better
and what Canada is doing to monitor this
ship given its NATO and NORAD
commitments so our talent intelligence
is five eyes intelligence so we are
closely monitoring many facets uh and
movements in that region for our part we
are sending another frigate over into
the the Baltic we are also ensuring that
we continue to get our aid over there as
soon as possible those 200 vehicles are
going to be going before the summer uh
the four tanks that we just announced
will be going as soon as possible as the
chief said we are making plans to
deliver those in the coming weeks and so
again
this is part of an overall Allied effort
and I was glad that the chief mentioned
that Poland is also sending the 2a4
variant Finland is also sending that
same variant so this goes to my point
about the necessity of Canada being part
of the Collective a common platform of
tanks that will be so important and then
finally I will say that on training
Canada has a very strong
and well-deserved reputation in the area
of expertise and training having trained
over 35 000 Ukrainian Armed Forces
members and we are going to be sending
trainers over to make sure that the
Gunners the drivers the loaders the crew
commanders and the maintainers of these
tanks are very well trained so that
Ukrainian Armed Forces members can be
the most effective possible on the
battlefield
foreign
symbolism and token it's not just
symbolism especially when you think of
two factors first of all we are part of
a global Allied Collective to ensure
that we are maximizing the amount of Aid
overall and the number of tanks that we
can send and you have to remember that
this has occurred in very short order
the meeting in Ramstein was last Friday
since that time numerous countries have
stepped up to the plate to ensure that
we can all be part of this Collective
furthermore Canada's contribution is
continually being assessed in terms of
the ability to get the spare parts
necessary to make sure that these tanks
can be maintained I want to stress that
maintaining tanks is difficult
especially in light of the complexity of
this vehicle this is not just light
changing oil in a car this is a need to
make sure that we have continued flow of
spare parts that are able to be received
to maintain the tanks and then to
utilize them where necessary to deploy
them whether it is in terms of make sure
we have Canada's Readiness whether it is
ensuring making sure that we are living
up to our NATO commitments and whether
it is term in terms of ensuring that we
are contributing to the overall tank
effort for Ukraine foreign
uni
come less
on that point he said in French the
words change but you at the outset
weren't even going to send lethal
weapons and now you're sending heavy
tanks so talk about that where how you
got there
so this conflict this illegal invasion
of Ukraine
has been
unacceptable from day one that hasn't
changed but what has changed is the need
to continue to support Ukraine with the
military equipment that it needs in the
short and the long term to secure
Victory and to reclaim territory
and so when Ukraine has asked for air
defense systems Canada has stepped up
with air defense systems when Ukraine
has asked for armored vehicles Canada
has stepped up with armored vehicles and
now Ukraine has asked for tanks and
Canada not only is stepping up today
with four tanks but is continuing to
evaluate what more we can do in the area
of tanks and military aid overall
that so what's changed as I said
Canada's actions Canada's contributions
are part of the broader NATO commitment
and our actions are very closely tied to
the actions of our allies and that's why
it's so important when you think about
our tank contribution that we are
sending the 2a4
vehicle tank in combination with our
allies so as I said there is
interoperability on the battlefield
right from the word go with the
Machinery with the equipment that we are
sending
victims I have to go nope
Mr White